bonjour messieurs fait merci d'être avec
nous cet après midi sur rt france allant
fontaine ça fait un mois maintenant que
vous êtes tenus de contrôler le passé ni
terre de vos clients quel bilan tirez
vous
et on a eu de fortes inquiétudes au
départ au départ de passes annie terre
il ya eu quelques
quelques contestations de clients
mais les choses se passent plutôt bien
point de vue présentation de ta
sanitaire l'impact du passé mais
économiquement est plus important alors
en résumé quelques joutes verbales
quelques joutes physiques
malheureusement est sûre d'aller pleurer
tact économique est très présent avec
des baisses de 10 à 15% selon les
régions paris très impacté et maintenant
la province à la fin des vacances sont
bien l'impact du pass sanitaire avec des
baisses qui sont de jeudi entre 10 et
15% bertrand legrand avec le
reconnaissent que ce pas salutaire vous
semble avoir été une bonne idée ce qu'il
vous semble primordial est ce qu'il ne
serait pas plus simple finalement de
rendre tout simplement la vaccination
clairement obligatoire pour tous
en fait ma kron avait décidé que
l'action n'avait que pas actional
n'existerait pas aujourd'hui on a un
pass sanitaire qui est insuffisant on
aimerait bien passer carrément au pass
vaccinale puisque on mélange aujourd'hui
des gens qui sont potentiellement à
risque avec un test négatif avec des
gens qui sont vaccinés qui eux ne court
aucun danger à partir du moment où ils
ont été vaccinées en terme de mortalité
donc les gens qui ont fait l'effort de
se vacciner je pense dans l'extrême
majorité en ont un petit peu marre de
faire des efforts croissants pour les
gens qui sont non vaccinés il est à
noter quand même que les vaccinations
est en croissance le nombre de personnes
dans les pattes dans les manifestations
de passes sanitaire devient de plus en
plus faibles et on voit bien dans nos
réanimation que par ailleurs elle se
contaminent de plus en plus et que donc
du coup par définition elles deviennent
immunisés donc c'est une haie mais des
manifestations qui sont joués par le
temps disparaître au fur et à mesure du
temps c'est un combat perdu d'avancé sur
un combat d'arrière-garde à la fontaine
que vous disent les clients est ce
qu'ils jouent le jeu est ce qu'il
présente beaucoup plus facilement
aujourd'hui le passé leader qu'ils ne
l'ont fait finalement c'est devenu un
réflexe à l'entrée des restaurants
oui les clients le présent facilement
et comme vous allez vous avez raison
précise et restaurants effectivement
dans les restaurants ça se passe plutôt
bien au niveau de ce qu'on appelle la
limonade c'est plus compliqué parce que
les gens s'assoient sur les terrasses
deux fils ils passent pas par l'accueil
est là les premiers bien sûr son
contournement sait très bien que c'est
plus beaucoup plus compliqué sur les
terrasses et en particulier sur ce qu'on
appelle le produit limonade c'est à dire
le service est ouvert c'est très
compliqué et c'est là où effectivement
on avait demandé que les terrasses par
exemple ne soit pas incluse dans cette
présentation du pass sanitaires comme
chez nos amis avaient d'ailleurs parce
que ça pose un vrai problème de
logistique et sa fausse aussi un point
d'accueil parce que la personne est déjà
à six et évidemment il faut lui demander
de passer sanitaire ciel là si elle n'a
pas et comme le disait mon interlocuteur
juste avant c'est vrai que c'est
compliqué parce que vous avez un navet
qui ont un test pcr à vous présenter
donc qui sont en cause le schéma
vaccinatoire tout c'est très compliqué
et nous
envoyer
une bonne connaissance de tout seul
système de schémas vaccinatoire et de
l'expliquer aux clients donc vraiment se
passer r j'espère qu'on va s'en sortir
très très vite j'ai vu que ce matin sur
les centres commerciaux saleh se
détendre j'espère que ça va se détendre
très rapidement et qu'on va sortir de
cette période là parce que c'est une
période très compliquée pour nos
employés pour nous patrons aujourd'hui
ce sont plus de 70 % c'est plus de 70%
de la population française totale qui a
reçu à un schéma vaccinal complet
bertrand legrand est ce que vous faites
un lien
acte entre l'extension se paie
sanitaires et ces chiffres sans cesse en
progression de la vaccination
oui c'est évident et je pense qu'il faut
remercier les restaurateurs et tous ceux
qui ont accepté de cette difficulté et
qui nous ont vraiment aidé parce que on
était au bout nous en tant que médecin
de des schémas d'arguments et on devait
avoir besoin de 7 entre guillemets
obligations et on sait bien que les
restaurateurs font tout ce qu'ils
peuvent pour le faire respecter on leur
demande pas vraiment plus le symbole a
été fait je pense que tout le monde a
compris que maintenant il faut se
vacciner et les quelques résistances que
je vous le disais de toute façon sont
amenés à disparaître de par le temps
autres au fur et à mesure du temps c'est
tout simple au tout simplement
mathématique donc oui je pense qu est
clairement monsieur fontaine peut être
assurée le pass sanitaire ne va pas
durer éternellement et on va pas
demander à tout le monde de vérifier le
statut vaccinal de tout le monde au fur
et à mesure du temps les gens seront sac
signer tout simplement alors avant cela
et depuis le 30 août la vaccination est
obligatoire pour l'ensemble des
travailleurs des salariés qui
travaillent dans des lieux qui
accueillent du public ou le pas
salutaire et déjà réclamé aux clients
alain fontaine l'enfant des salariés de
la restauration notamment
s'est prêté au jeu là aussi
il ya deux questions dans votre question
la première c'est que le 30 août et fait
effectivement été une date butoir et là
c'était vraiment vraiment compliqué
parce que si vous voulez on n'était pas
prêt notre la population
de la restauration c'est un jeune qui
n'était pas obligatoirement antivaccinal
mais qui était surtout un peu s'ils
gardent et donc ils pensaient avoir du
temps et on a vu ça dans toutes les dans
tous nos restaurants avec des jeunes qui
se sont retrouvés à la date butoir dont
certains restaurants de nombreux
restaurants même sont encore pour leurs
employés dans le schéma vaccinatoire
donc soin tests pcr toutes les 72 heures
soit congés payés pour certains on pense
que ça septembre tout ça entre dans l'or
à part à part bien entendu il faut pas
le
faux pas me cacher a pas effectivement
une partie de la population dans des
emplois et de l'instauration ou même des
patrons qui sont anti vaccins et par
conséquent la va falloir beaucoup de
pédagogie va ça va parler va falloir
voir comment on s'en sort parce que ce
qu'il ne faut pas et je le répète
souvent il faut pas à cause de cela les
compétences on en a on a déjà passé dans
la restauration ont si en plus on perd
des compétences pour des choix de
société être anti vaccin est un choix de
société il va falloir quand même un peu
réfléchir et on espère que la
vaccination va progresser pour que la
pression sur les anti vaccins se relâche
un peu parce que nous on peut pas se
permettre de perdre des compétences un
dernier mot avec vous bertrand legrand
vous sent optimiste dans vos propos
quant à cette lutte qui dure depuis un
peu trop longtemps maintenant contre
elle à la propagation de l'épidémie et
pour vous il n'y a pas de craintes à
avoir il n'y a pas de raison de redouter
un regain de l'épidémie
dans la foulée de la rentrée scolaire
non on a maintenant les exemples et
contre exemple vous avez l'exemple
d'israël qui est souvent pris en exemple
où on voit bien que la mortalité
n'augmente pas et elle limite j'ai envie
de vous dire s'il convient de circulent
et qu' il n'y a pas de mortalité et capa
d'inde effet sur la mortalité des gens
vaccinés on n'en a pas besoin d'aller
beaucoup plus loin ce qui est dommage
c'est pour les gens non vaccinés qui
veulent pas comprendre effectivement
pour cela on perdra les compétences mais
on les perdra d'une manière qui est très
qui est déplorable donc effectivement il
faut pas en arriver là il faut qu'il
soit raisonnable alors moment donné
quand on voit que le combat est perdu il
faut se résoudre à la réalité
malheureusement il ya toujours des gens
qui sont en dehors de la réalité et ça
malheureux on peut pas y faire grand
chose c'est comme ça donc un moment
donné on regarde ce qui se passe on
appréhende le risque on voit bien qu'il
ya pas de risque vaccinale on le mesure
tous les jours on voit bien que quand on
n'est pas vaccinée ça se passe plutôt
mal je vous renvoie aux antilles et on
voit bien que dans les pays fortement
vacciner il n'y a pas de résurgence de
la mortalité et qui a pas de résurgence
des hospitalisations donc le vaccin est
efficace merci beaucoup bertrand legrand
médecins généralistes merci à vous alors
fontaine président de l'association
française des maîtres un restaurateur
merci d'avoir participé à cet échange
sur rt france